what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have the first
full official trailer for venom let
there be carnage we got the teaser
trailer
a couple of months ago and now we have
the full trailer and a better look
at carnage how carnage comes to be and
how cletus cassidy gets out of jail now
we get a tiny
little bit more about cletus cassidy's
backstory
why he wants eddie brock to cover his
story before he's put to death
we see what eddie brock is up to and it
seems like his life is actually kind of
sad at the moment we get some new cool
shots of shriek which i'll explain
in this video and of course lots and
lots of awesome action of
carnage so in this video i'll break down
everything that you need to know
scene by scene and if you're new to the
channel and you love marvel and want to
stay up to date on all things venom let
there be carnage
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos and since
the venom let there be carnage trailer
is now out hopefully that means that the
spider-man trailer
isn't that far away so ignoring the tiny
little teaser that they give us in the
beginning of the trailer
it starts with eddie and venom
overlooking san francisco eddie now has
a ducati
motorcycle a very very fast motorcycle
but if you notice his arm it's actually
venom that seems to be driving which
makes sense if you crash
venom can take the fall and nobody gets
hurt we had a big motorcycle scene in
the very first venom film and it looks
like we might get another one
in the second one venom then says eddie
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys and we cut to a scene of venom in
san francisco
on top of a building sitting very very
much like spider-man
this is a very spider-man-esque shot
right here it almost looks like it's
going to be spider-man jumping off the
building
shooting his website or doing a backflip
off the skyscraper into the city so big
parallel here to spider-man and
hopefully we see the two of them
on screen together in the next film now
when venom says we should be out there
snacking on bad guys
it actually shows venom and eddie
rescuing somebody venom is in a back
alley and it looks like he saved this
woman on the right from this person that
he has in his arms and it looks like he
probably eats this person
hints the whole snacking on bad guys
which is a rule that eddie placed on
venom in the very first film you can
only eat bad people
if you have to eat anybody at all and
this scene looks an awful lot like the
scene in the first venom film
when eddie and venom first eat a person
but then we see how eddie and brock are
currently living together what their
situation is like and what eddie's
mindset is like
and it doesn't look like it's doing too
good venom says i am a predator
i need to be free and it looks like
eddie is almost treating venom
like a dog he has a tire for him to chew
on in the apartment and if you notice
the tire actually says snooki on it
at first i thought maybe this is some
kind of a joke as in venom hates snooki
from the jersey shore
and is actually gnawing on the tire and
kind of gnawing on her
but it isn't spelled the same way so
maybe this is just a little joke but
there's nothing really in marvel that
has anything to do with snooki at least
not the name maybe this will be
explained in the movie but if you notice
venom actually hits eddie you can see
venom's body in front of eddie and we
can see him hit eddie back he hits eddie
to the floor and soon goes back inside
of him and this is where eddie says
you've got to get control over your
aggression but eddie said right before
that i need to be free it looks like
eddie is pretty much trying to keep
venom inside of his apartment which is
why it's a chaotic mess we can see
holes in the ceiling he's got the tire
for him to chew on and in the last
trailer that we saw
he was making him breakfast and it
wasn't really good but here we see eddie
is actually kind of paranoid now over
venom venom is an
alien symbiote and eddie says if you
don't get control over your aggression
we're going to end up in
area 51 where they study ufos and aliens
so eddie's worried at this point that
people are going to figure out about
venom
people are going to realize that there's
this monster alien inside of him and
take him to do tests on him and it seems
like he's really stressing about that
but you can tell that this doesn't
really fly with venom eddie says you
live in my body you live by my rules and
he puts up a sign that says
no eating people however it looks like
it's pretty hard to control an
alien symbiote as when eddie says that
venom looks at him and breaks his nose
and he says sorry at first but it
doesn't look like he has too much
sympathy because he says
let me fix it so i can break it again
and then hits him again in the face
and then he calls him a loser after so
eddie's life right now probably isn't
too ideal
now during this scene we see the
ravencroft institute
now the ravencroft institute in marvel
comics is actually located in new york
but it does look like for the sake of
the movie it is going to be located in
san francisco
the ravencroft institute is a maximum
security facility that specializes in
the treatment of superhuman criminals
and it has a pretty big connection to
cletus cassidy aka carnage
the facility was actually originally
built for cortland cassidy who was an
ancestor of cletus cassidy and he had
been driven insane by a cult and became
a murderous cannibal
he eventually escaped and murdered his
wife molly ravencroft hence the name
eventually cletus's mother would end up
in the ravencroft institute pregnant
with him and he would be born
inside of the institute and it looks
like venom let there be carnage at least
a part of it is going to be about
carnage taking down the raven institute
clearly cletus has a bad past there and
it looks like his lover
shriek is also in there as well we see
her inside of a glass cage which we saw
before
screaming which is her power she has the
ability to manipulate
sound in maximum carnage shriek and
carnage escape together and are lovers
and then they go
on a killing spree together now here we
get another shot
of a maximum security prison in which
cletus is held in it's not sure right
now if it is the ravencroft institute it
looks like it could possibly be the same
facility but it could also be a separate
one as well
and here's where the post-credits scene
from the first venom film is kind of
explained
we learn why cletus cassidy wants to
talk to eddie
it clearly seems like cletus has studied
eddie's work
and inside of this universe where they
exist in eddie could have even been
responsible for finding some evidence
that got cletus cassidy put in jail but
we'll see if they go with that story
route but cletus has clearly picked
eddie because
he wants him to specifically cover
himself a serial killer
and here is where we kind of start to
see how really insane cletus is
he starts going on about how people love
serial killers
and it looks like he's given eddie some
of his drawings that he's done
in prison we see a very large chapel
drawn which of course is going to be
explained in the movie that we've seen
before
and on one of the pictures on a tree it
is written
to the strife was given between the
suffering now this is actually
a poem titled prometheus written by an
english romantic poet lord byron
it was written in 1816 and it's
basically about a person who steals from
a god to help humanity
of the poem the solitary suffering
defiant hero is meant to empower readers
reminding them that the revolution
begins with individuals who dare to
imagine the future differently
now if you notice it has a heart on it
which could be
from shriek perhaps the two of them
being mentally insane could have
imagined a future where they were
actually heroes
and perhaps the carnage that cletus
keeps talking about
is some sort of a revolution now it
could be a revolution against those who
have locked him up in an institute or it
could simply be a revolution against
society
in itself either way i think we know
carnage is coming
now in the background we have a post
from the daily bugle and as i pointed
out in my last breakdown for the venom
teaser trailer this is the same exact
daily bugle from the sam raimi
spider-man universe
it is exactly the same implying some
type of connection there i'm assuming
this will kind of be explained in
spider-man no way home
but on the newspaper it says inside the
mind of serial killer cletus cassidy
so here it looks like eddie is simply
typing up his story about cletus now
here there's a little bit of a twist on
the venom carnage story we find out how
cletus actually gets the carnage
symbiote
now i could be wrong here but when eddie
is talking to cletus inside of the
prison cell
it seems like cletus is kind of implying
that he knows eddie has the venom
symbiote in him
he says what's mine is yours and yours
is mine he then attacks eddie
bites him and gets some of his blood or
the symbiote inside of his mouth
and he even makes the statement i have
tasted blood before
and that is not it so regardless of
whether or not cletus knew that eddie
had the symbiote inside of him
this is very clearly how cletus gets the
carnage symbiote now here's the little
twist they put on carnage
in the comics carnage is the offspring
symbiote of
venom it's his son and that is
essentially what we are seeing here in a
certain type of way
part of the venom symbiote gets inside
of cletus and then when they go to put
him to death
and inject him with the poison this
poison interacts with the symbiote and
the symbiote defends
its host cletus and it looks like it
kind of infuses with the poison
and then becomes carnage now from here
we have a couple of different scenes
that they're kind of trying to make look
like one scene here but they are
separate
one is carnage breaking out of prison
and as we see here carnage is
definitely way more intense than venom
as the officers shoot him we actually
see
a giant hole right in the middle of his
stomach which is crazy to think about
because
if you realize that underneath him is
cletus
you should simply see cletus when this
symbiote makes a hole inside of the
symbiote but
no everything shoots through it we can
see clearly through this hole
meaning carnage is actually morphing
cletus's body and forming a hole inside
of his actual body
so it looks like cletus and carnage
could actually be bonded
more than venom and eddie and after some
amazing scenes of carnage breaking out
of prison
us seeing many of what he can do
including shoving his tongue down
somebody's throat to kill them we see
him eventually get
shriek out of the ravencroft institute
we see the two of them
riding in a car away together explosions
happening in the background
and this is the same car we later on see
shriek inside screaming at the top of
her lungs
destroying everything around her showing
how powerful her screams actually are
we then hear cletus say i'm not a crazy
man
i am a vengeful one and that's what i
think this
is all about getting back at the
ravencroft institute the institute that
locked his mother up the institute that
he was born into and the institute that
probably stripped him away from
his love shriek and unfortunately art
eddie brock and venom are what's
standing in his way
then we arrive at a cathedral we saw
this one in the very first teaser
trailer and it clearly means something
of
major significance to cletus he gets out
of prison goes to this cathedral and we
can see him here standing in front of
these candles
it's here where we then see venom
actually kind of get scared
oh
that is a [ __ ] one you need to come out
right now
this implies that red symbiotes are
actually much stronger
and scarier than normal symbiotes this
is clearly taken back from their home
planet where all of the different
symbiotes used to interact with each
other and since venom kind of withdraws
himself from eddie talking about that's
a red one we can
definitely assume that the red ones are
stronger and a lot more intense
and probably ruthless which of course is
what carnage is all about
and as he says this we get a look at
carnage who looks like he's very ready
to attack
lots of different weapons coming out of
his body all
very very sharp but eddie makes him an
offer that venom can't refuse he says
i will let you eat everybody if you come
out venom says you promise eddie
promises and then venom says
oh yeah and comes out from here we see
that carnage
actually has the ability of projectiles
i'm sure venom could do this too but
carnage is just going at it
firing off basically blade-like symbiote
structures of himself
at venom and it doesn't look like they
stop until venom eventually gets to
carnage
and from here the two of them will no
doubt battle it out in what's going to
be
an epic scene now one of the last scenes
that we get
is of cletus and shriek walking away
from a burning building again i'm
assuming this is the ravencroft
institute and the two of them are
getting
vengeance on the institute like cletus
cassidy said
i'm a vengeful person shriek screams at
the top of her lungs as i mentioned
before
seemingly breaking the car that she's in
and everything else around her
it looks like cletus actually goes to
the store that venom and eddie go to a
lot and he kicks the clerk in the head
now it doesn't look like the woman
that's usually there
mrs chen but it's clear that cletus is
searching for eddie
and one of the final scenes i want to
point out here is when
venom is seemingly jumping away from
carnage with a pole in his hand but if
you look behind him
it looks like the carnage symbiote is
absolutely
huge it's not in the actual form of
carnage it's more like
a wave of the symbiote trying to capture
venom now this could be one of the final
scenes where venom kind of figures out
how to break the symbiote apart or this
could simply be
pure symbiote chasing venom and right
after this
it's a blink and you'll miss it moment
but we see carnage kind of separate
himself
from cletus cassidy we see just his head
talking to cletus cassidy just like
venom did to eddie in the first venom
film and in this trailer as well
the trailer ends with cletus saying
eddie you feel like home to me
like family and now they kind of are
because they're both the host of
symbiotes but it looks like cletus
and carnage are definitely going to be
having the upper hand
all throughout this film probably all
the way up until the end
now of course the very final scene is of
anne
revealing to eddie that she is engaged
engaged to dr
dan lewis who we met in the very first
film and clearly eddie and venom are not
okay with this because even though eddie
says that he's happy for them
he does slap him in the face and what
this shows us is that even though this
movie is going to be
very very intense it's still definitely
going to have some comic relief
now overall i think carnage actually
looks pretty dang good it does look
intense which is something that i was
worried about and i think a lot of other
people were worried about as well
but that scene of carnage shoving his
tongue down that police officer's throat
leads me to believe that even if this is
going to be rated pg-13 it's still gonna
be just fine
but let me know what you think about the
venom let there be carnage official
trailer what did you think about carnage
what did you think about the trailer
overall
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any future
videos
please give the video a like and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof